who is Austin's dad with the Black  Clover manga in its final Arc we still  don't know the true identity of asta's  father because asta's mother had a  unique Magic that made her dangerous to  be around there are many interesting  theories about asta's father and why he  was able to get close to her without  having his life force drained there is a  theory that asta's father is actually a  devil or that he might even be the time  magic Devil asteroth Himself but  probably the most popular theory is that  asta's father is the wizard King Julius  no macrono the more we learn about the  final villain Lucius the more we realize  that Asta is actually the perfect weapon  for taking him down since Julius knew  about lucius's plans for decades some  believe that he fathered our stuff for  the specific purpose of defeating Lucius  subscribe to the channel for more anime  Mysteries like